we're told that maya and doug are
finalists in a crafting competition
for the final round each of them will
randomly select a card without
replacement
that will reveal what the star material
must be in their craft
here are the available cards i guess the
star material is the primary material
they need to use
in this competition maya and doug both
want to get silk as their star material
maya will draw first followed by doug
what is the probability that neither
contestant
draws silk pause this video and see if
you can work through that before we work
through this together
all right now let's work through this
together so the probability that
neither contestant draws silk so that
would be i'll just write it another way
the probability that
i'll write mns for maya no silk
so maya no silk and
and doug knows silk
that's just another way of saying what
is the probability that neither
contestant draws silk
and so this is going to be equivalent to
the probability
that maya does not get silk
maya no silk right over here times
the probability that doug
doesn't get silk given that maya
did not get silk given maya no silk this
line right over this vertical line this
is shorthand for
given and so let's calculate each of
these
so this is going to be equal to the
probability that maya gets no silk
she picked first there's six options out
of here
five of them are not silk so it is five
over six and then the probability that
doug does not get silk
given that maya did not get silk so if
maya did not get silk
then that means that silk is still in
the mix
but there's only five possibilities left
because maya picked one of them
and four of them are not silk they're
still
silk as an option it's important to
recognize that the probability that
doug gets no silk is dependent on
whether maya got silk
or not so it's very important to have
this given right over here
if these were independent events if maya
picked
and then put her card back in and then
doug were to pick separately
then the probability that doug gets no
silk given that maya got no silk would
be the same thing as the probability
that doug
gets no silk regardless of what maya was
doing
and so this will end up becoming
4 over 6 which is the same thing as two
thirds